welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
we're live here in Miami
we had Jerome Bettis Pro Football Hall
of Famer on earlier in the week and I
mentioned he was the first NFL player to
spend a few days in studio in the
history of NFL Network and then we had
Sapp on the other day who along with
this guest was the first player to have
a regular segment in the history of NFL
Network and now what he has become is
truly something else a Pro Football Hall
of Famer is also a co-anchor of Good
Morning America and also on Fox NFL
Sunday where there's a whole host of
casts of thousands coming up this
weekend and he's currently wearing one
of the exclusive limited edition Super
Bowl 54 capsule collection in
celebration of the NFL's 100th season
that he has put together ms X by Michael
strand for NFL along with his buddy Carl
banks from the Giants I could go on and
on but the most important thing is this
man helped me live out my dream to give
away cash and prizes on his way I love
seeing you and I I truly will you called
me and you said hey I wanna do $100,000
pyramid I'm serious
it is my life's dream I said he's lying
like this is not but you were saying
when I was there I was I was into Italy
into it you're great at it by the way
well thank you and I was so upset that
Joel McHale who was going against me
along with you know the people were
actually winning the dollars that that
he got to go to the winner's circle
first and I was so I was so upset you
know what though I loved about it
because you do this show and you don't
make any money okay the people you're
playing for other people to make a lot
of money populate intially but even when
you don't make it to the winner's circle
your competitive side come down and I
know you're over there clapping oh hey
great Jovi kill but I can see you're out
and everybody's eyes and they're like
you will lose the next round I will get
to the winner's circle and it's so great
the setup is so great your staff is so
great your grab it was a true dream come
true what we love having
be surprised if you get a callback I
will take that callback and honestly I
could go on and on and on and on about
your your list of accomplishments and
everything that's going on but I do want
to get in first of all congratulations
on the announcement I guess you made on
Fallon that you're number 92 is getting
retired by the Chinese yeah it's gonna
be retired thank you thank you I don't
know when yet but sometime during the
seasons gonna be retired that that's a
heck of an honor and being able to join
some of the other numbers that have been
retired in the career the guys have had
there for me I'm just happy I had a job
and could support myself and not move
back in with my parents now I now I got
a my jersey retired along with Eli who's
deserving as well yeah what was it like
that day whether I mean you were part of
the large big blue alum class that came
together for his retirement announced
yeah you know it was awesome it was good
to see so many guys some I played with
some I have it right but to see them all
come to bed together and come back and
have so much respect for Eli then we
also had Ernie Accorsi there who the
general manager they you know back in my
time who also drafted Eli just to see
executive two players and and all come
back because like a family and he meant
so much to all of us because I know
without winning a Super Bowl my life is
different and and Eli was the big
catalyst and a big reason we were able
to do that and I'm just grateful to be
his teammate he's always been such a
nice man and and I think his demeanor
that everyone said he doesn't show any
emotion it was perfect for New York
because we had a lot of other guys who
were colorful we needed our quarterback
to be focused and he with all those
things to help the team went to Super
Bowl Michael Strahan here on the Rich
Eisen show more I'm sure you're already
hearing it that there's a lot of talk
about your 2007 Giants team for this
very weekend number one your defensive
coordinators according to the defense
for the Kansas City Chiefs and Steve
spagnolo and number two is that yes
you've got a an MVP quarterback on one
side albeit one season removed in
mahomes but for guys who can put their
fingers in the dirt defensive line and
go hunt and have
you don't have to scheme your way to the
quarterback that's your guys in that
role that you had in handing the lone
loss to the previously undefeated
Patriots in that Super Bowl do you see
any similarities other than just what I
just threw at you yeah I mean it's kind
of you you've everyone asked who's gonna
win and be honest with you I don't know
right now I got a you know just meditate
on it or that the Brotherhood that's a
glazier move save it for you Vaughn
saver don't Sunday no glazier wah
exactly glazier says nothing to nobody
unless it's the guy or people or ladies
who are paying him so I understand it's
a bunch of gibberish anyways but it's
interesting to me to watch Deepak Nolan
what I literally just came here from
their practice okay and to see him with
the defense that it's built differently
than our defense with Bill you know the
defense definitely built differently
than our defense I think the challenge
they're gonna have is really the running
game and and everyone has criticized
Garoppolo not everyone is criticizing
but a lot of people said we don't know
if Jimmy G can win the game but I think
when they've needed him to throw the
ball he's thrown the ball well he's done
everything that they've needed him to do
but the number one priority in my
opinion to stop in that running game is
if the Chiefs are gonna a lot of
quarterback to get on the field and do
what he does best and on the other side
being at the NFC Championship game
watching all the four linemen come off
the ball I'm like I don't know we were
that explode kidding
we were explosive and we were we were
great trust me III you know I'm not just
bragging but we were great at what we
did yeah but we weren't as big as these
guys we wanted six seven six eight three
20 and run like you're 240 you know Bose
is not as big but he's like one little
muscle and his motor never stops I just
think we hit our hot spot and these guys
have been hot all year long and it's
gonna be a big challenge to slow down
that line and mahomes
have a lot of weapons they're gonna have
to get their running game going as well
to kind of counteract just guys rushing
up the field you got to learn to hit
some seemed to slow that rush down yeah
Michael strand here on the Rich Eisen
show a few more minutes left with you at
you
you as well as Howie and Terry and
obviously Jimmy getting in the Hall of
Fame it was an amazing moment that you
were able to celebrate on live TV the
other day that was pretty cool the
greatest thing about Jimmy's moment is
that Jimmy's had other opportunity that
have passed for him to make it into the
Hall of Fame and I think he had gotten
to the point of where when the Hall of
Fame came around he really didn't want
to hear about it sure he was kind of
like I'm over it I don't want to hear
about it doesn't matter well you know
Harry Carson from the child I think it
weighs on your heart you in it and it
even I saw the video with Drew Pearson
broke my heart I can see that like that
really broke my heart because it means a
lot to the guy than someone all the hard
work they put in so when David Baker
came out Curt Menefee were the only one
who knew the rest of us had no idea they
actually came out late because he was
watching a halftime show in the green
room and said oh my god this is a moment
you know Jay got to get in on a moment
right so Jay ran out there is yeah and
joined us and to see Jimmy get choked up
and start to cry before a guy who I've
never seen like that and then when he
said the whole time he wasn't breathing
I'm like I'm not giving you
mouth-to-mouth well you better somebody
who was gonna give him mouth-to-mouth
for you to pass out that was our debate
and we're all looking around on simple
Curt by default you knew and didn't tell
us are you surprised this though you
give a mouth the mostess gotta take calm
out you know that yeah sure the whole
you know what Curt said yeah well Jimmy
with a nice key of teammate to work with
all these all right so you're wearing
right now some of the garments that are
has been especially made for the limited
edition Super Bowl 54 capsule collection
in celebration of the NFL 100th season
you partner with Carl banks yeah big
g3 sports and then your MSX by Michael
Strahan for NFL collection quit
something fun Carl the ex giant big big
in the garment business that done well
with g3 for a long time we want to do
something fun for the NFL celebrating
100 years of the NFL and they also did
the 100 best player the NFL history
we're we're outfitting them with their
jackets from my line as well for like
their Hall of Fame jacket but we're we
have a different color that our guide
beyond Sanders help be a part of that a
new exhaust yeah but we wanted to do
this and this is but we'll do something
for men and women to celebrate Super
Bowl 54 right a lot of people can get to
the game a lot of people can't so we
wanted to do something that you can get
something to feel like you're attached
so you can go to shop dot Michael
Strahan comm you can go here at the
Super Bowl to the Super Bowl experience
also a lot of pop they're pop-up shops
around around the city for you to buy as
well but just something to be a part of
the Super Bowl and celebrate the 100
years and they're three colorways the
three thousands of color ways for men
I'll make sure I get you some all on
there for for women so we women are
included you know Suzy wants take your
wife I know that you know my wife many
times in before right before I let you
go I know you got a run but I want to
point out the show that you did with
Robin Roberts and on on ABC and about
Kobe's passing yeah and honestly I when
I saw you up there
i I thought we interviewed Kobe a couple
of Falls ago and asked I asked him the
question about coming back and playing
with LeBron Dan he was he bristled he
said he takes it as an insult that
athletes can only play that when they're
done retiring like it's thought of them
it's the only thing that they are built
to do and that's the only thing they
want to do or will have the same mamba
mentality to do he bristled and I
thought of you and I thought you were
the perfect guy to have
because of what you have done since your
playing career well I'll tell you what I
had a cool relationship with Kobe and
when he was did beer basketball which he
won an Oscar for right
he had a vent he was kicking it off I
Tribeca Film Festival so he calls me to
come in and interview him in front his
panel of hundreds of people to talk
about his project and you could see he
had the same passion for stuff outside
of basketball and he had it and he
worked just as hard and I just love that
he would come on GMA and do the within
our series talked about his books and
all these different things and just get
a chance to spend that kind of time with
him and laugh with him and joke with him
it was special and you don't realize how
special until unfortunately something
happens like it happens and and that
what we did dispense a report on Sunday
I walked home I was telling you earlier
I walked home from from the studio and
it was surreal like I didn't realize
what it actually happened and it still
had this sunk
sunken in yet but he was a special guy
who definitely set the bar very high
that in life is not all about just
s'okay I'm a professional athlete and
that's it you know you can do other
things you can accomplish so much more
and then 41 years of life he's done so
much that it's taken people it's it's
effective people doesn't didn't know he
about basketball really right and and I
think that that says a lot about what
you've done in your life that so many
people want to celebrate you and and I
was thinking I'm talking to a friend
earlier today it's like okay what would
Kobe do and what would he think about
all of this and I think he would say
okay I appreciate it
now get focused and get back to doing
what you do celebrate you know we
celebrate his life and celebrate what he
left us and that is the mentality to
always do your best go as hard as you
can and make a change well said and I
know I left out Tom Rinaldi's name but
it's Tom Tom is the offering man is
great and antithetic and Robin Roberts
is as we know the gold standard for sure
but I I was kind of proud because I
don't think you were just up there
because you're an ex-athlete you're up
there because you're a host I appreciate
it and that
and that means again what you have done
with your thank you your life here you
know how I feel about you man
and I honestly we could have spent this
entire time with me introducing you with
all the stuff that you're doing but just
to review you're on FOX starting at 2:00
Eastern Time leading up to kick-off
sequel 15 four and then everybody check
out again this collection of limited
edition Super Bowl 54 capsule collection
and celebration of NFL's 100 season love
you Michael string let me brother they
actually we're gonna get sit there and
watch you guys you want to respond to
this are you guys talking about
they met Mike there's your answer
but Miami Mike and Chris Brockman making
their their special appearance in this
interview with Michael strand
good to see you stretch for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app